you know there's probably like ten blog
posts that matter the most if you're
gonna do a start-up one of them is the
Paul Graham essay do things that don't
scale where he's talking about with
Airbnb early on and if you're kind of in
the startup world just fast forward 30
seconds but if you're not you like the
story if you haven't heard it
so Airbnb is in Y Combinator they're
struggling Airbnb he's not really
working
they have like 20 customers or something
low and they go into programs office
he's the advisor from Y Combinator and
he's like okay so tell me how it's going
and they're like well you know it's
small and really growing he's like okay
but tell me what have you learned from
your customers you've been out there
what you learn and they're like well you
know most of our customer customers are
in New York and they're putting their
apartments up he's like they're in New
York yeah like most your customers in
New York yeah he's like what are you
doing here like go to New York you need
to go to New York now and like why are
you in San Francisco if your customers
are in New York so he sent him over
there and what they did which is
something that nobody else was doing was
if you ever saw an apartment listing
before the photos look like because
it would be somebody on their crappy
mobile phone at that time taking a photo
of a dirty apartment and listing it for
rent and so it was like the worst sales
pitch and so they started themselves
going in they said hey can we send up
they would tell their customers hey we
want to do professional photos of your
place it increases bookings by 40% are
you open to that and then they would
show up as the professional photographer
and be like hey by the way I'm the
founder and they would take photos and
the Airbnb listing started to look great
and everyone told them this won't scale
and they also thought this won't scale
and to an extent it did because even now
today there's a sort of fleet of
photographers that will come and take
photos of your place to list it because
it was just that important and they
found a way to make it scale I think
that's a great story
another thing that shocks people is I
think even if you have hundreds of
thousands of users may be as high as
millions you could really I've done this
with us I will just call and talk I only
need to talk to about 10 people right
and I can see the pattern that
represents tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of people right I could you
could just tell you it's so like what
you could do is a be test and wait
if you're just starting you're not gonna
it's not gonna be significant and that
could work fine if
just call 10 people you really get the
information right totally
I was talking to Emmett so Emmett's the
CEO of twitch where I'm working and what
you know being at a big company has all
these different weird things that aren't
really related to my core interests
which is startups so I asked him it all
the time just tell me about the early
days and so I asked him I said hey when
you guys were pivoting from justin.tv to
twitch was that obvious he's like no
dude at justin.tv like less than two
percent of the watch time was on video
games it wasn't obvious that this was
the thing to do he's like I just liked
it and I thought there was an option and
he goes and then I talked to a bunch of
customers and I said do you have your
notes from that and he's like yeah I do
and so he sent me his notes from the
initial conversations he had with all
these streamers all these customers and
we published this no no probably not but
I was reading through them and it was
fascinating so first was just like first
lesson was just go ask the founder CEO
about the early days I bet you they have
a bunch of resources that are awesome
well he sent me the old pitch decks and
stuff like that I think I sent you one
slide which was my favorite slide the
title of the slide because he was a
progress update for their early
investors yeah and it just said we're
like a bulldozer in a field full of
flowers and he's just there was a list
of all the that got done that month
I was like this attitude like if I said
that today at 2:00 which it would be
like what is this maniac saying like why
is your slide so aggressive but that's
how they were early on so then he had
all these notes of his customer
conversations and he always tells
everybody had to it she's like go talk
to people by the 6th conversation you'll
hear the same thing over and over again
it takes six phone calls basically to
figure out the pattern and by the sixth
one you'll know and you'll you won't
even want to do 50 conversations you'll
be like alright I can predict what this
person's to get us a before they even
say it after six that's awesome I think
we've got ourselves another clip clip it
what do you want to first of all share
that deck with me again and also African
ask him if we could make that pump yeah
I will ask him actually cuz it's pretty
cool
what do you want to get what do you want
to do the one thing I can share out of
that by the way he asked three questions
I said you know oh customer interviews
is there a whole skill set to learn he
goes no dude I had three questions I
said what do you like about your current
platform what do you dislike about your
current platform and what will it take
to get you to switch to twitch and
that's what he asks every single
customer and then he just heard the
common things and he would build it and
go back to me said
you told me this is what it would take
for you to switch two weeks later here
it is are you ready
and then sometimes are like no still
using okay cool what's next we're just
like you buried that three questions
that's badass
just to wrap that up if you want to
learn about this stuff I think the best
book I've ever read on this is called
the mom test yeah I love that a jack
recommended me that book yep it's
fantastic it's the best tiny book to
like the long blog post 50 pages in
terms of your business life might change
yeah a mom test
[Music]